two buttons you can only press one a  instantly get a million dollars or b  have a 50 50 chance you get 100  million dollars we're gonna up the one  million for you though let's say yeah  for  me no because i'll be honest with you i  am so rich no this wouldn't even affect  me it wouldn't affect me that's why i  can do this internet [ __ ] for nothing  it's like you're not paying me so i  don't give a [ __ ] i don't press any  button i don't need your [ __ ]  i'll take the 10 million i'll just press  the button take the 10 million and go  home because i have  where's your car  when would you switch over no because i  have an investment can talk about it  right now sure um it's in a bitcoin i  have an nft  have you guys heard of these nfts i know  that i could take 10 million and within  hours i could turn it into the 100  million i'm good when it comes to  investing